this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to let's talk about
Donnie Brasco that's right some of
Johnny Depp's and Al Pacino's greatest
performances at that a bunny I don't
remember a bunny and Donnie Brasco oh
shit did I order Donnie Darko it's dead
you certainly did and let me tell you
why it's the greatest movie ever made
hustle on a crap let me tell you why
this is the most over a high pretentious
bull talk is that ever existed I'm not
doing this because Donnie Darko has two
very polarizing audiences one side says
it's one of the most mind-blowing movies
ever made and the other side says it's
the equivalent of American Pie trying to
be American Pie people love to talk
about whether or not this is a game
changer or just an excuse for artsy kids
to say you just don't get as if we
needed more excuses for that yeah if I
don't understand that that means it
sucks like a movie Eraserhead
he was never once at the end of a pencil
yeah that's the thing I don't care what
the fan base is say I just want to give
my own take really so you dress up as
fan bases in a video just to say it I
kind of referenced ironically
referencing us I don't even know what
your fan base is like I have no idea
that's the shit you'd wear I have no
idea that's the kind of stuff you would
say and frankly I don't care I know
there's a lot of opinions and theories
about this movie and you're welcome to
them I'm just saying I'm gonna give my
report on it no one else's just seems
like a lot of extra editing simply to
say you don't care you have to take time
to find these clothes and change into
I'll just leave me alone
fine I'm gonna write a million theories
as to what this opening man yeah no I'm
gonna punch a football I don't know
whatever my family's does let's take a
look at the film that launched a million
blog post this is Donnie Darko the film
opens with a boy knocked out having
apparently tripped on his bike ah the
mountains of Minnesota
he gets back on and rides on home to a
slow-motion family it ends with the
spider are they all bang the girl happy
reading
I know readers are already having a
field day with this but honestly I'm
just wondering what production assistant
put that Care Bear sticker there yeah
figure out the symbolism behind that one
artists it's all secretly the origin to
Swift heart rabbit and I'm not gonna lie
this might be one of my favorite most
random opening lines to a movie I'm
voting for Dukakis I just want to help
Jon Lovitz career maybe when you have
children of your own I'm not gonna
squeeze one out so I'm like 30 so you
know in a year that's Maggie Gyllenhaal
is Elizabeth and Jake Gyllenhaal is
Donny playing the incredibly stretching
roles of brother and sister and it
wouldn't be an early 2000s movie without
debate J's Van Til eighth grade
excuse me she'll be well in a well by
then maybe you should be the one in
therapy then mom and dad can pay someone
$200 an hour to listen to all your
thoughts on mom and dad why stop taking
your medication my teacher said this was
called shoddy exposition teachers a call
me Ani Donny's mother tries to come in
to make him feel better but his awkward
acting continues to rebel I don't
recognize this person today then why
don't you start taking the goddamn pills
bitch fun fact tommy was so actually
rehearsed that lying with him bitch
bitch
her son just called me a bitch not well
but he did actually in all fairness most
of the acting in this movie is pretty
good as Donny goes back to taking his
medication again and sure I guess this
is as good a time as I need for the date
[Music]
a voice seems to call to Donny as he
walks outside and encounters DC
cinematic reboot of Bugs Bunny you know
the rain girls inside you shouldn't
steal her stick
Elisabet comes home late but it turns
out she's right in time for shitting her
pants when we'll roll boom announces
cannon fire and because we're artsy we
can just stop the scene right here son
son Ben what are you doing Donny wakes
up on a golf course with the end of the
world written on his arm wow that sounds
like the opening lyric to a Don McLean
song so uh let's stay off the links at
night okay
and pay no attention to how Patrick
Swayze never got rid of his heavenly
glow from ghosts Donny goes home and
finds part of an airplane crashed right
into his room but the rest of the plane
is nowhere to be found
this makes the family kind of
celebrities as all the kids talk with
them and even share smokes with them
what happens if you tell mom and dad
about this
well that names just a conflict of
interest seeing how we know what her pet
dog did to Ariel I have a spirited away
in the rats joke left after that I'm
done hey no David Blaine went to this
school
she's just angry because she got voted
most likely to be thrown under a bus
[Music]
wait a minute this was an early 2000s
movie random slow motion - fast motion
edit it was a weird time when editing
like your toes controlled the remote was
artsy here I thought happy deathday had
the weirdest goddamn mascot but pug
McMahon nipples here wins this round It
was as though this plan had been with
him all his life
- Barrymore plays random casting choice
number 20 is Donnie's teacher the to her
credit she did help produce this movie
so it's only fitting she plays a role
mocking kids about missing the point of
her story why did the children break
into old miseries house they wanted to
rob him journey a few had actually read
the short story which said a whopping 13
pages would have kept you up all night
you would know that the children find a
great deal of money she I remember how
my kids were made fun of by bullies when
they didn't do their homework yet still
raise their hand do the assignment
Donnie Darko I have no question I just
wanted to say your name that sounds cool
I just registered and they put me in the
wrong English class you look like you
belong here can't even think about Jill
Fred that that's just weird
where do I sit sit next to the boy you
think is the cutest quiet only I may
appreciate my childish remarks oh and
the teachers not joking either she means
it as the girl eyes the boys checking
her out and some of the girls Joanie get
up
[Music]
and immediately fire for her abuse of
power om you know she said she on the
way back Donny comes across an old lady
who's roaming the streets and constantly
checking this one mailbox she seems to
however was for something in his ear
what'd she say she kept masters of the
universe off her resume Donny also
apparently sees a therapist I'm a new
friend real or imaginary she asked that
like he was choosing between sparkling
water and distilled imaginary do you
seem a little too okay with that answer
you know I think that show did some
damage at a school they watch a video
about controlling your fear you know
that class as Donny has another vision
that night well now we know what happens
when Camille del Toro doesn't nestle due
to a busted water main and general
douchebaggery but it looks like
someone's hitting on Donny's maybe baby
I like your food I'd say that line is
terribly written but coming from a young
Seth Rogen I believe he said that
do you want to walk me home sure I'll
admit I was torn which bird sound effect
to put there so I'll just play them all
[Applause]
so he walks her home and they make
awkward small talk Donnie Darko how kind
name is bad it's like some sort of
superhero or something
what makes you think I'm not I read
comics I know Mysterio is the bad guy so
that's enough for relationship material
if they decide to go out afterwards his
therapist recommends hypnosis she asks
about his imaginary rabbit friend
apparently named Frank I'd like to hear
about your friend Frank oh he looks so
much with Lola bunny
human ticks I love human ticks the
teachers ask everyone the school to show
their penmanship to see if they can find
out who graffiti didn't vandalize the
school never questioning couldn't the
vandal just fake the handwriting
Donald dark
okay tell me I'm not the only one who
thought this one they heard that Donald
Darko but dammit movie let's get to what
really matters Smurfette fucks all the
other Smurfs why do you think Papa Smurf
made her Papa Smurf didn't create
Smurfette Gargamel did she was sent in
as Gargamel's evil spy your Smurfs ology
is light-years beyond my Fraggle Studies
he gets another visit from Francis
Bacon's Roger Rabbit who says he's a
time traveler but his little sister
interrupts who are you talking to I was
just taking my pills here whatever can
you tell me to swim class in a pool
that's filled with rats I'm sorry I mean
the promise in a panicked Donnie returns
to school where they teach everything
falls into two categories fear or love
seriously what class is this a big shock
some of the students think this is kind
of stupid just place an X on the life
line in the appropriate place you can't
just lump everything into these two
categories and then just deny everything
else be like this movie which only has
awkward that confusing he gets in
trouble for talking back to his teacher
buddies Dale returns back to school to
talk to another teacher about what is
known about time travel the teacher
gives him a book that it turns out was
written by that crazy lady roaming the
streets later the therapist asked what
that woman whispered to him Donnie what
did Roberta sparrow say to you she said
that every living creature on earth dies
alone especially those who to fortnight
dance memes they really die alone he
sits with his dad and Friends watching
the world's clearest eighties TV when
James Cameron suddenly takes over
directing
[Music]
so this is what happens when you eat
Lunchables the day after they expire so
the look lead them to a closet where he
finds a gun
I guess that's fitting seeing how we're
shortly followed by a character we'd all
love to shoot is entirely too many young
men and women today they surrender their
bodies to the temptation and destruction
of drugs alcohol and premarital sex how
much do they pay me to be here
cynical high school student I was so not
prepared for this are you telling us
this stuff so we can buy your book
because I gotta tell you if you are that
was some of the worst advice I ever
heard right this has an anger be
prisoner well as principal I clearly
have no control over this or any movie
schools that aren't run by dumbasses the
parents are shocked but the students
cheer whatever this was supposed to be
as he hangs out we're all media things
young people hang out I'm living from
furniture outside I haven't seen stuff
like a lot of really messed up stuff
before we have an actual conversation
let's cut away because no scene in this
movie lasts over two minutes each vessel
travels along vector yeah it's kind of
like cafeteria line editing that way you
need next get what you need next
get what you need next because of this
the pacing always feels a little off
it's less like a movie more like Mario
just jumping from level to level except
instead of going from the Mushroom
Kingdom that underwater is philosophy
class to science class well if God
controls time in all times pre-decided
he talks about the path being like
traveling through God's channel but the
teacher says he has to stop talking
about it I'm not going to be able to
continue this conversation why I could
lose my job
oh no tell me this is not a setup for
God's not dead for if your arguments so
clear why there's so many movies about
it
[Applause]
[Music]
I love naps I mean look at them they're
so sticky and they get your mail where
it needs to go they even have little
designs on them so they can look
different from one another it's genius
god help me I don't care it's genius but
neh postage has gone up say it has not
but it has thankfully stamps.com is
there to help because with stamps.com
you have five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail that kind of savings
really adds up especially for small
businesses plus stamps comm is
completely online which saves you time
that rhymes
no more inconvenient trips to the post
office
stamps.com automatically calculates and
prints the exact amount of postage you
need for every letter or package you
send your never go for pay or under pay
again stamps.com brings you all the
convenience of US postage services to
your fingertips buy and print official
US postage for any letter any package
any in all caps class of mail using your
own computer and printer steps duck
makes it's so slap-happy easy they'll
send you a free digital scale which
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
knees
stamps.com also station money those
money they give you postage discounts
you can't get at the post office
including five cents off every
first-class stamp tell me there is no
more there is anything you can do at the
post office you can do at your desk for
less I use dance comm because I'm really
busy and don't have time to go to the
post office even though I love stamp so
much and I can't live without them so to
have them delivered to my home is yes so
much
and right now my viewers get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
what yes what yes
see for yourself way over 700 thousand
small businesses use dance comm just go
to stamps.com and click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in nostalgia that stamps.com
enter nostalgia
you
[Applause]
so Donnie here's a surprise mopes around
for a while until he comes up with an
idea with his girlfriend for a project
to sell a life-changing product these
are glasses an infant can wear while
sleeping that protects peaceful images
when did you stop and think that maybe
infants need darkness but maybe darkness
is part of their natural development
wait are you gonna like the next few
decades what if the parents like put in
pictures of Satan is that what you'd
show your kids didn't your dad like stab
your mom might I add to my totally
realistic teen dialogue I like your
boobs the teacher waits a kind 10
seconds before finally stopping them get
out no wait I want to see where this
goes
that's it scars her so much it gets
Donny to first base time to follow that
up with the hottest of all date movies
Evil Dead hey that reminds me if you
were a tree what kind of tree would you
be
but we see who Donny's really on a date
with and damn she fell asleep in the
first five minutes of the movie I
thought for the love of the game was the
only Sam Raimi film I could do that
spoken like a true fairy he takes off
his mask to reveal he's really some guy
and he turns the movie screen into a
portal
it's last car show so like any good
boyfriend he leaves his date behind and
tries to figure out a way to burn down
the house of a motivational speaker rule
you get to choose which title is more
symbolic I'm still trying to figure out
the care-bear meanwhile at the school we
see a production going on of the
timeless classic overly blatant teacher
commentary failure is not an option
Anthony if you feel the need to vomit up
there just swallow it
thank God our schools aren't PC or soo
happy or else we wouldn't be able to
have this totally realistic scene oh
[Music]
those jocks at dance recitals Donny's
little sister for Florence with her
group the dieter faces as he starts
burning down the speaker's home he has a
painting of Sean Penn and Sylvester
Stallone and somehow it's the exact same
picture oh yeah his girlfriend slept
throughout the whole movie damn those
famously comfortable old theater seats
the fire reveals though that the speaker
had a kiddie porn dungeon and yes those
are the exact words the news anchor uses
the following day dad plays golf with
that guy when he said his balls weren't
clean I didn't mean while Barrymore is
getting fired from her job probably
because she's an awful teacher we don't
think the methods you've undertaken
are appropriate what exactly about my
methods do you find inappropriate okay
we saw two minutes of your teaching I
was like putting a fire me sign on your
back
we are losing them to apathy proscribed
nonsense
they are slipping away why can't you
just judge them on entry and force them
to sit where their hormones desire
she takes the news pretty well this is
why you're fired
however the teacher defending the
pedophile kid's day figure that one out
it's obviously some kind of conspiracy
to destroy an innocent man she is
Donnie's mother to drive the girls to
the dance competition it has no car Tony
this character is I do admit I get a
laugh out of this line sometimes I doubt
your commitment is bargain with all the
obsessing over Donnie Darko how has this
line not been turned into a bigger deal
no it has like a lot
I apologize Internet I should not have
doubted you on this meanwhile Barrymore
exits her job gracefully nice well done
e I guess tries to do something kind I
promise one day
[Music]
well that was unexpected totally
justified but unexpected he undergoes
hypnosis again and admits to burning
down the speaker's house and also
admitting that the bunny told him to do
it how could I say that sentence without
this being a comedy right now let me
turn into a California reason they're
wolves up at the stop motion movement
human tits with their parents out of
town don't even Elizabeth throw a
Halloween party but daddy's girlfriend
shows up saying her mom's gone
you call the cops he said I should be
the house and that I should go to a safe
place
don't listen to her man she fell asleep
during Evil Dead she is not to be
trusted I guess some people are just
born with tragedy
okay the proper reaction to half be
kissed on that line is the same Jenna
Fischer had in blades of glory
but it's Dappy census going wild as
liquidator schlong leads the way once
more
that's the twist he was an anime
character the whole time I bet this is a
spin-off the boy who left through time I
[Music]
got a kid out here before someone makes
a meme out of that scene I just did oh
god it's too late he feels like he's
running out of time but suddenly the
bullies from before show up threatening
their lives yes I missed the part where
they went from name-calling to multiple
homicides boy that escalated quickly
great wear pantyhose so nobody can
recognize you and then take him off to
tell witness to go away the kind of
idiots who would rob your own house a
car steers off the road distracted by
the roaming old lady and ends up hitting
the girlfriend donny feels terrible
because he had to put a letter in the
mailbox that the old lady was getting
and it looks like the driver is
guess-who demonic thumper are you guys
doing in the middle of the road oh
you're like my dad flying over the wrong
crop wait I have another Independence
Day job ok so you can kinda see where
this was going
emphasis on kinda as Donny gets up the
next morning and sees the sky is one big
clogged toilet the sky potty takes the
engine of his mother and sisters flight
back in time and seemingly himself as
well placing him back in his world when
the engine crashes thus killing him get
it trust me it's ok if you don't what
happened what was his name Donny Darko
no really what was his name the girl
waves the mother waves the little boy
waves and everyone sais that at least it
made more sense than the Lanco leaders
so there you go Donny Darko hokey and
awkward or strange and insightful yes
for me there's two sides constantly in
battle with each other one is the actual
story and characters most of them are
either unrealistic random boring over
the top or distractingly silly the story
is well just jones from scene to scene
never really feeling like an organic
flowing narrative i guess you could
argue that's part of the idea but it
comes across less like planned chaos and
more like clumsy filmmaking the other
side though are the concepts and ideas
but gives you enough pieces of
philosophy science and surreal imagery
but still leaves it vague enough that
you can put the pieces together however
you want for certainly elements of
classic science fiction and psychology
you could even argue a lot of religious
martyr ism so on the one hand it is very
thought-provoking and can open up
interesting points of view on various
ways people can be lost while thinking
they're found the only openly Oise
character seems to be the link to all
these people ideas and even science that
all seem to be very solid and belief but
compromised in practice but you have to
get through characters that don't always
talk how people talk or do what people
do where they intended to be that way
possibly but that can not only be hugely
distracting it can also be very
unrelatable which i think we're supposed
to in some way or another relate to
these characters so it's tricky I
recommend it for the seeds of ideas it
grows in one's mind and the somewhat
abstract way they present them but I do
so with the understanding that you're
gonna get some clumsy moments that don't
always add up so I guess I like it when
it's not supposed to make sense and
dislike it one is supposed to make sense
a weird conclusion but would you expect
anything else from a weird movie that
mentis Towser could a guy remember it so
you don't have to I like your boobs
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing the
hearing Health Foundation the hearing
health foundation's mission is to
prevent and cure hearing loss and
tonight as through groundbreaking
research and to promote hearing health
this is the largest nonprofit funder of
hearing and balance research in the US
and a leader in driving new innovations
and treatments for people with hearing
loss and other hearing disorders their
implants alone have been proven to be a
valuable treatment option for people
with profound hearing loss benefiting a
hundred and twenty five thousand people
in the US and three hundred thousand
people worldwide with an A rating on
charity watch as well this is an
organization that does a great deal of
good for those born without decent
hearing click on the link or share the
link to see how you can make such a big
difference
[Music]